there's no didn't I I don't know how to
explain to you I don't know the words to
tell you what it feels like to truly
truly [ __ ] be alone and happen no I
don't know the words I thought I can't
describe how that feels
you know it's been 40 years I'm still
crying that my pain
Oh 53
so James where you from originally
I'm from Indiana Louisiana look what's
sitting treatment and what what brought
you to LA okay well what would brought
me to the LA I don't just want different
I different
I'm gonna check online
everything to be different I was raised
by my mother to dad wasn't around
no compared to never better it's awesome
then my dad died when I was eight
separate though I said no and he married
had in the past month I hate coming me
now yeah from what I can remember from
early stage early years of my life I
have been exposed to all of it
I knew you were about sex before I was
into didn t video like that my mother my
father
normal esta you doesn't think that's
what I would what I was being he got
back three times
I guess so better became violent to stop
when I was this is true I mean what age
do you think this all of the yeah Matt
you did throw from the earliest stage I
remember really yes
before I was I remember being at my mind
right now
I remember being a child wave I must
just become individual you told me to go
in there just gonna be ready
really I don't no idea what we go wow
yeah so I mean so and you know there was
a reinforcement and as a child I was I
was a subjected force I didn't have a
choice if I said no I'm still gonna that
was very fun
Maldon brother was doing he was doing an
8 a 5 years old
no way yeah our Father we had a
different father
my guru appearing on a regular base that
out that I was not partisan that's what
was going on with going on i cup
everything all the swag all this [ __ ]
the problem is with the Tommy they sell
me that rape and sexual offense it's
okay as long as you care mutters this is
what you do to show the other person how
much you care about that's what I was
taught it was okay to rape that it was
located to do it was okay to force
myself and do what I want
I was taught that that was okay
verbal abuse psychological used is
nothing emotional psychological piece
idiot with a tongue stop series of it
and they tell me well when I was 16 I
didn't I got into trouble
what were you arrested for rape rape of
who house those you raped your mother
and this
or I'll stick to your wrist from the
family
so that means now it's completely about
myself but
I had no one that you talked to
I had no one to correct no one shoulders
brown but I've never the worst feeling
in the world is waking at the more late
night at night on asleep
it's true
no doubt I'm by myself I hadn't known
it's his day right now I have
not one time remember would do anything
to know what happened
she allowed it over him I did nothing
except when I was talking
because for me I didn't know it at it
now the differences are true did not
know the difference between
through experience that was perfectly
normal okay
performance so the first time she
actually talked to me after that that we
gesture why did that I just I said we
mean why and she said one utilize I said
ma much that didn't you
you know
damn everywhere
I would like before
see your life no we
but I did and kids do some violent
extremely but it's not you know example
to man or they're ugly convicted friends
all robbery attempt to say sorry 10 to
second
all my crimes or violence
so that's harder not to kill not killed
I've been in prison for killing me I
didn't I did all my [ __ ] I did like 26
years over a period of time over 26
years I did 18 year prison sentence
first 10 years that I just first general
in prison the what
right this bit yes
which actually
it just sort of happened
[Music]
you know
do I really I would say I don't know
which
I really do
cherish magic
I met I met I met Europe we looked
our work with teachers
I do what I want and there's nobody
gonna change anything about me
and I do whatever I can become justice
is going just as violent
it's the deck smuggler and I don't like
Western Europe Ireland
[Music]
packet without creating myself I can see
Dewey - how'd you read that dog I can't
okay
it's not I could do that
just nothing
[Music]
that's a [ __ ] he's nothing cash war
together I can't change Oh did you I've
tried but I can't
goddamn and that's like taking a soldier
putting them in their army this is what
they do and they tell him it's okay to
kill she'll kill him he's got a gun he's
the enemy killing folks kill them kill
them
give me gives out the service he gives
the duty getting fired
they're putting him in prison telling me
what's wrong what son of a [ __ ] you
trained him you told you that's the [ __ ]
that one I hope I had no control
we get you diesel I hear horror man I
have no one
look at me man it looked me straight in
a bunch of [ __ ] night
I can't call me I can't call my brother
I can't call my sister I can't call my
graph I can't call nobody but you can't
so why are you telling me I don't know
how you hear when you've got somebody
and I don't but
you